when you see a movie and it's really
really well-designed you you can't
imagine that film taking place anywhere
else good production design Fermi has to
move you and transport you to a place
that you become immersed in and you're
so engrossed in a movie on every level
the story of the character is the visual
of it that you're not paying attention
to the technique of it I hope that I'm
not looking at it as a decorator I'm
hoping that it's much more subliminal
and that I'm affected much like an
audience is I don't want to be
distracted by the environments I want to
just be invited to disappear inside of
it the best production design you don't
notice the look of a film and how it
fits the whole movie is very important
it can't just be standing out on its own
I don't usually go for very operatic
sets that don't seem to fit the scope of
the film what I find most notable is
when it just is a quiet backdrop for the
actors and that the whole project is
incredibly cohesive I'm not interested
in InDesign that beat you over the head
I'm not interested in a film that cries
out look you know I was designed and
kind of interested in that flamboyant
so I look for something that works with
the script tells you something about the
characters gives you insight into them
without bludgeoning you I'm not
necessarily drawn to the ones that are
sort of funky on the head and say well
for me I like to see a world that that
is new and fresh and been created
especially for the movie like any other
art medium is very subjective and
personal and I think for me there's
always a moment when it crystallizes and
I'm watching something and I think this
is you know really really incredibly
done and many times it's it's often not
because a production is is sumptuous or
you know rich and in period detail but
rather that everything just feels right
what the center girder does is there
just to be there for the for the story
to support the actors to support the
storyline to support the characters in
whatever way it needs to but never
overpower them if it moves you if you
believe it if it was serving the story
in the character then then you get me I
always want to see what design supports
the story the best it's all telling
helping to tell the story and helping to
tell the the history of the characters
that you're watching on the screen you
see in this amazing movie and afterwards
when you pick it apart if you feel like
this movie couldn't have been told
better any other way that's good
production design
you